one year since myanmar's army overthrew
the elected civilian government the
country appears to be in the throes of a
civil war at least according to one
former u.n official the army has stepped
up violent attacks against citizens and
pro-democracy protesters are organizing
into armed groups to fight the
government but it's an uneven contest
and the military appears willing to do
anything to stay in power
the myanmar regime's response to popular
resistance tells a story of
indiscriminate violence
from the first protesters gunned down
just days after the military coup
to air strikes launched in a remote area
in december
sending people fleeing
into neighboring thailand
more and more
the conflict is becoming a civil war
and street protesters are deciding to
take up arms
we hate the military dictatorship and
we've decided to end it by rooting out
the military from the country
we promise to help and try our best to
finish them off when the war starts
these anti-coup activists have joined an
ethnic rebel group putting their lives
on the line
against a regime they've sworn to
resist their decision a sign of
desperation
of having no other option
i see the stage sort of set for a
prolonged conflict neither side
seems willing to back down it's just
very difficult to see how the conflict
will will diminish
will reduce
um in the in the near term even in you
know over a period of several years
neither side may be strong enough to win
an outright victory
meaning villages and army bases like
this one will continue to burn
and earlier i spoke to myanmar human
rights activist ted suey winn who's on
the border between thailand and myanmar
helping refugees flee the violence i
asked him to describe for me specific
instances of violence perpetrated by the
military
um so overall the military right now so
we call them as a fascist military so
they are you know brutally killing
torturing in people everywhere you know
not only in the ethnic area you don't
think the the the coup stated they
uh
like you know they make a lot of
problems in many places for they
right now what they are doing right now
in the in the mainland area is
definitely the thing that they did in
the ethnic areas you know many years ago
like the rape deutsche and d key you
know like for example you know one of my
friends um
he she was a
trans woman and she was like arrested
brutally in in mandalay like you know
crash back while she was riding the
motorcycle they they crashed out with a
car and then they just you know brought
her to the prison and they tortured her
and they humiliate her in many route
ways because you know like uh they they
have the burmese militaries this is how
they always do in the ethnic area and
also like you know they raided the
houses at night and then they just
randomly shoot with the people so that
even yesterday and this morning today uh
in in this morning uh like an infant y
uh was tied by the burmese military's uh
bombarding to their village and
yesterday in chieftain also one uh why
was also being killed by the obama's
military but the killing in burma by the
burmese military is happening every day
and everywhere
i mean just what you're describing is
just it's just it's just heartbreaking
to hear it and therefore i'm guessing
some people are describing the situation
in myanmar as a civil war i mean would
you agree with that classification
yeah i totally agree with that so we are
already in the fifa war and then our
people are only preparing for our you
know uh right to defend we are
predicting right to defense for
ourselves
there are also reports a threat of
people forming armed resistance against
the military in the form of these
people's defense forces or they're
joining ethnic armed rebels do people
see no other option of resisting the
military government
um we are actually doing two weeks one
is between it on the ground like you
know having uh organizing protests every
day in the cities so like we are having
the protest every day already you know
uh 355 defense last year so we we do it
every day every week you know in many
places and uh of course you know doing
the protest nowadays in the cities are
very dangerous and very uh like you know
uh only a few people can do this but you
know our young people that generation z
uh stay you know trying to do this even
for today you know many youth groups are
organizing activities in the cities you
know showing that you know we were not
let the defense military rule the
country but in the other hand the the
the other look the the young people are
also taking m because you know uh we
uh they think that you know we cannot
win this military by only doing the
peaceful way that you i also do respect
for referring for their decision because
this is really
the depth deficient of them so like many
youth groups have formed you know their
own resistance groups in many believers
and also some of them also joined with
the ethnic revolutionary groups and some
of them tried with the national unity
government's uh uh people defense forces
myanmar human rights activist that say
win there talking to me earlier now
through this entire crisis the
international community has been accused
of not doing enough to stand up to
myanmar's military leaders the u.s the
european union and the uk have imposed
some sanctions on individuals and
companies but foreign governments are
continuing to send weapons to the coup
leaders and protesters on the ground say
they fear they have been abandoned by
the world the u.n special envoy to the
region has called for renewed
international efforts to bring about
change
i've called for greater action
including in the security council
to help lay down the building blocks to
narrow the trust deficit
and initiate talks about talks
on peace
national unity and democracy
now the road ahead will be long and
difficult
but the time to act is now
and time is running and joining me now
for more is kaywin he's founder and
executive director of the burma human
rights network and he joins me now from
bangkok mr winn has the response from
the international community been
ineffective so far
in in order to
answer unquestioned i think
there isn't any total uh inaction there
is action but that there has been
symbolic action
so what we are asking the international
community to have a concrete action that
must be effective action
or so
imposing
any sanction effectively so that need to
include
oil and gas enterprise
something that generating millions of
dollars and millions of money
going to into the military's pocket
which they use they spend the money to
buy the weapons and also
uh international arms embargo which is
crucial to stop the military from
committing cruelties in burma
but yet this hasn't happened in the past
year and some 1500 civilians have been
killed why is the international
community hesitant to impose such
targeted sanctions and these arms
embargoes as you're demanding
i mean so far the middle the sanctions
coming from eu and u.s and uk and canada
but
but you see that it is not only enough
but un secretary first of all you and
security council
you you don't see any roles of u.n
security council in this crisis it
totally uh failed u.n security council
has been failed totally of obama
so what we what we are seeing is
international community uh is divided uh
like china and russia is one side and
they try to support and stand with the
military despite the military is
committing heinous crime crime against
humanity
and we launched a report today called
brazen tyranny of uh myanmar military in
this report we clearly identified how
the military committing genocide i mean
committing crime against humanity uh the
widespread the very systematic
no no please go on sir
yeah
so so the military is called the way
it's cool
conducting the cruelties and the
atrocities mass killings and murders and
and as an attack on the villages
is quite similar very same sway it is a
very systematic and very similar way the
way the military committed genocide to
the hindsight against the romanian
people
we were just talking about this in fact
with an activist who was on the
thailand myanmar border about the
atrocities of the military but i just
wonder just to go back to the point that
you were making earlier about a divided
international community and you talked
about china and russia being on one side
and other countries being on the other
side
can i just ask you directly is it the
support of china and russia that allows
the myanmar military to continue to rule
so far the military receiving arms from
china and russia
but one thing is that china is very
close country to brahma china has also
influenced to other arms group in burma
like aaa like kachin like
like many many other
northern alliance so there are many
uh the arms group tied with in
existing thai opera operating kaibab
border they have a very china has a very
strong
influence also china has influenced
some arms group in indian border
so
russia seems is
remote very far from burma but it has a
very strong influence thousands of
burmese military training taking trading
training in russia all high-tech and and
uh you know assaults and a lot of
uh air force and maybe all different
sectors they are taking uh training from
from from from the russian army
uh so that the two countries have a lot
of investment in arms market in in burma
and also they have a political support
too but however they these two countries
didn't recognize the military as a
government of burma
so that's still there is some hope you
know you see that there is some uh there
is some role some hope that if
uh other countries like us uk france and
other country can convince these two
other power to do something against the
you know the military could possible
yes hoping that happens we leave it
there for the time being thank you so
much for joining us k win of the burma
human rights network thank you sir